good morning John it was named that by
the Celts sir it was named something
close to that
it's literally from a Sanskrit word we
can feel the age of this place
linguistically but that's true of a lot
of words like for example the word
linguistics is rooted in a word for
tongue that stretches back even before
Sanskrit but the thames hasn't just been
there in name it's actually been there
the whole time it was there before it
was called the Thames it was there when
the first people came when the Celts
came when the Romans came when the
Normans came and during that entire time
up until about fifty years ago it was
the default garbage dump for all of
those people got something you don't
want throw it in the Thames another
important bit of context here the Thames
is a tidal river it's close enough to
the ocean that it's levels are affected
by the tides so sometimes it's full and
sometimes it empties out and during
those times when it empties there are
places where the shore gets exposed and
in that mud you can find the leavings of
millennia
coins pipes bottles pottery shards
musket balls tooth brushes human remains
John right now I'm on my way to see a
mudlark the self-assigned name for
people who walk in muddy places in
England to see what they can find this
mudlark has a youtube channel link in
the description and I watched that
channel and I loved it and I find myself
in the enviable position of being able
to fairly easily get in touch with and
meet the YouTube creators that I
absolutely love so I wanted to do it oh
we are your neighbors no you're a weirdo
well I can they kind of know they might
know about this weird ring secret weird
room it's not a person yes that's a
whole skull it could well be Roman but
you know look at all your Papes thing
now I've got some lovely Roman posturing
oh my god
yeah just give your child some lead yeah
it's a chew on Victorian baby bottle
just a perfect breeding ground for
bacteria so it was just terrible for
babies to be given milk in this but it
is okay to have the worst-looking
Teletubby oh it's for a thing that isn't
that you're just gonna throw away I know
I still I said would I put that out of
that I believe you I'm in London for
VidCon and it's hard not to feel the
context of history in this place I know
that's probably not true if you live
here unless you're the kind of person
who dips their hand into the banks of
the Thames River to see what comes out
but I feel it and it's also hard for me
not to feel the history of my own life
and my own industry and work when I'm at
VidCon and it's good to have a chance to
think about what we will leave and are
leaving behind how much more we are
creating and what pieces of it will be
found in the future and what they will
mean to the people who find them I don't
think about that a lot it's probably
best not to think about it too much but
maybe I should think about it some John
I'll see you on Tuesday
Yaman airport hotels so i gotta wait for
a spell as behind the sky I'm waiting
for the brain to go by waiting for the
plane go by waiting for the brain to go
by there's people flying in that sky so
I'm waiting for the plane to go back
[Music]